la marne à la baguette
votre âge hymne à la famille de la
région à la salle arena par à ophélie
souhaité nous devrions
connaître et on en a marre de neige dans
la raquette
ou des barres à mine est une pâte à base
de chaleur
m'a
rattrapé coluche
je
[Musique]
je ne
c'est un peu long
entre avec des associations
cinq mille ans chaque ville il ya les
associations partenaires avec les
travailleurs actuellement encore bones
et
en ordonne les maisons et ils font la
distribution au niveau des freins
[Musique]
ça
on
le
nous on est loin on peut pas aider nos
familles on peut pas donc on essaye
d'aider un petit peu comme on peu donc
on a répondu à cet appel on essaie
d'abord d'apporter des médicaments donc
en deuxième temps on va essayer
d'envoyer un container où il y aura
démontré ford et de la nourriture qui
peut être stocké pendant longtemps
[Musique]
m